hey guys welcome back to the evan and
katelyn podcast
now with one less appendix
and and your your voice is i can
just hear the difference in your voices
i'm sure everyone will oh you want my
scrunchie to play with
you can have it scrunchy i wonder i
wonder why my voice is like that i guess
it might be because of the tube
or maybe because i didn't use it much
for a few few days or something
i think also you're kind of being
careful to protect it to not have to
cough oh yeah i don't know i don't want
to cough because that hurts
yeah so you're kind of like protecting
the voice
saving it all whisper podcast oh
asmr now i think that uh
looking through the comments one of the
the comments i got a lot was like
i wonder why you didn't go to the
hospital earlier
the can you're talking about the
comments on the video we posted the most
yeah yeah
and in the social posts in which you had
appendicitis
yeah so yeah we filmed a video when i
had appendicitis
and um we did you know i had
appendicitis
pain for probably four or five days
we went in on the fifth day or so which
isn't
ideal i would not recommend that
well they said most people come in on
the second or third day
because like that's the point where the
pain gets to be where people are like
something's wrong this isn't normal yeah
just uh for you it was five
i think that there's like a few
confusing factors
well one caitlyn got the flu or
something
i it wasn't the flu i had like a small
cold
around like just after fourth of july
um and then i had it for a few days and
then you started feeling kind of crappy
yeah like with a light fever and some
cold like symptoms
so we're like ah whatever i had you
probably got
yeah and then after that your stomach
started bothering you yeah and i've had
off and on stomach issues ever since our
trip to thailand yeah basically ever
since our honeymoon honeymoon yeah
yeah and i have other like ongoing
health issues so
i just thought it was like a combination
of a couple things
like clearing up at the same time and i
thought man this is particularly bad but
yeah it eventually got so bad and i
think the thing that really
cued me off to it was how much my
stomach
just hurt it was just
like like pain it wasn't like
upset stomach it wasn't anything like
that it was just like
my stomach is in region area
the whole thing was like in pain and i
couldn't sleep for like two nights in a
row and i'm like this is wrong
so here's the interesting thing i knew
i i knew that you were having some
trouble sleeping
i thought it was more like i didn't know
that it was your stomach
keeping you awake because you had also
had like a migraine yeah
and some like headache and neck aches so
and that's usually the thing that
like if something's gonna keep you from
sleeping it's like head or neck or
shoulder kind of pain yeah and so i knew
that you weren't like sleeping the best
because of that i should have
communicated more
and i knew well here's the thing though
it was kind of hard because so
oh yeah um we we had
filmed the video when you felt um
you know just you were not at your
at your top even though i don't think
anyone would know if we hadn't like
pointed it out
um but we we filmed the video when you
weren't feeling 100
because uh we
usually put out videos every other week
we
um when we moved we pushed
everything one week farther in the
future to buy us a little time we pushed
everything as far as we could
and then because of like sponsor
scheduling stuff
july we couldn't push any farther so
that meant
we like ate up one of our um uh
like in between video weeks in july so
we were gonna have two videos in a row
which is for us pretty hard to do with
like
streaming and the size of our projects
and the time things things
the times that things take to to do yeah
so
we um you know for filming the video
we'd put it off a couple days because
you didn't feel great
and then one night you were like i'm
feeling slightly better this evening
than i have let's just try it
yeah i think that that was a really big
complicating
factor in the whole thing that that that
like
i was just focused on like trying to get
good enough to work
i wasn't actually like caring about
myself too much
i was like okay i just need to like save
up all of my energy
and again we thought it was like
everything like a cold or something yeah
yeah and then after we filmed it because
we had waited
a couple days more than we normally
would have that meant like the time i
had to edit it
was more crunched and so as soon as we
were done filming it
i was in editing mode all day for like
the next two days straight
and i just lay on the couch for two days
straight yeah
just like trying to survive but the
thing is i didn't know it was your
stomach
i thought i just thought it was like
cold and fever like i remember you being
really fatigued
and like you would try to do a couple
things on the computer a couple things
in the garage and you're like
i'm so tired i need to go lay down but
but i didn't know it was your stomach
and i wasn't
because i was in like editing zone like
hardcore
gotta get this done if i want to meet
the deadline editing zone
i like wasn't checking in on you as much
as i probably normally would have
yeah you know i think and i think you
weren't like coming to me with things
because you were
like oh she needs to kayla needs to work
you know
yeah i think that that one big lesson
learned from this is like
we probably need to not have deadlines
that tight
so that like if one of us doesn't feel
good we can focus on
each other and ourselves and you know
that
normally don't tough situation to be in
we normally don't have deadlines that
tight we've been doing the every other
week schedule since like
december because we we
um knew that we were pushing ourselves a
little bit too hard so we wanted to
to try that and we can only um this is a
little bit behind the scenes but
typically the way we work with sponsors
is we'll sign up for like six months at
a time
so our sponsor schedule is usually
booked for six months so if
you know we're ever like hmm i think
we're working a little bit too much
we need to cut back we kind of have to
wait six months till that change
we i i think looking backwards of course
hindsight is 20 20. but we should have
used the move as an excuse
to cancel cancel a sponsor we should
have
and you know we we haven't canceled a
sponsor
just because we wanted to like ever
no like i think once we canceled a
sponsor because of like logistical
concerns or something like well the
sponsor needed to change the schedule
and that didn't work with us so we
mutually decided to just cancel that
month
that's the only time we've we've
canceled one we are professionals
a professional but yeah we probably
should too seriously
we probably should have um canceled one
for the move instead of just pushing
at the time you know we moved like
end of may early june was kind of like
the process of the busiest period and so
we thought like oh by
like late july we were so wrong
we'll have enough time to like get a
little bit ahead and do two projects
back
you're so wrong super wrong um
because like as we were moving and all
of that we had to make
content we started streaming again
pretty quick
but yeah so um
so all that put together um
hello who's at the door um uh if it's a
package they can just drop it off
um all that put together um
i think was just kind of like the
perfect storm of
neglecting your health yeah you know
what i mean yeah and it's
you know it's easy in hindsight to be
like we should have gone in earlier
but you know it's also hard to know
and also in the past once before you
know
we've gone to the er for you and ended
up they just couldn't find anything
wrong and
you felt better by the end of it and it
was just kind of like well
it's fine i guess you know it's fine i
guess
um one one thing that i have to say is
uh i'll give a shout out to uh
william osman on the safety third
podcast he was actually talking about
the appendicitis that he had and the
pain that he experienced
and listening to him talk about his
appendicitis
kind of made me think i think i might
have appendicitis
so that's when i started doing more
research into appendicitis because
i thought it was just some sort of a bug
or something like that
yeah so i'm glad i just happened to have
listened to that like a week earlier
and thought of that but i have to say
like even
like waking caitlyn up i felt guilty i'm
like oh is that am i
blowing this out of the way the morning
we went to the morning we went to the er
when i went to the er i felt silly i was
like
am i fine is it like is this
me like with a life-threatening
condition or am i just fine well you
know it's an interesting thing
um that i think i realize a lot more now
is like so i myself have only had to go
to the er once and it's when i like
busted my lip roller skating and i
needed stitches
you know we had gone that one time for
you before and ended up
you know they couldn't find anything
wrong and then we went this time
and i think like in movies and tv
if someone's going to the er it's it's
kind of like
oh you know when you need to go like
it's urgent or
you're crazy you're bleeding or you
broke something or you just have a
sudden
pain and you're like you know um
and then being there it was like you
know i was kind of like
if if evan's able to like you know like
we're just walking up
calmly and telling them hey i think we
need to check in and they're like okay
i'm like is is it should things be more
urgent or like
what is everybody else around here like
dying but like no
there's plenty of people that are very
calm and collected
and can walk themselves yeah and i think
it made me realize like
i think just go in if you think
something's wrong it doesn't have to be
like
at an insane point i think movies and tv
shows
have blown up like in our heads
what like status you need to be at
before you go into the emergency room i
think that's that's definitely true
and like i needed to go to the emergency
room you definitely did
like like there was like i couldn't have
gone to an urgent care
couldn't have gone to a doctor no none
of that like i needed to go
to the emergency room that was the
proper place
yeah you know it's kind of sad huh when
i woke caitlyn up to like
say hey i think i might have
appendicitis and i think i might need to
go to the emergency room
oh no and then like the two of us hopped
on computers
like that morning like while my appendix
was like
rupturing and the two of us just sat
there like googling hospitals
trying to find good ones that accepted
our insurance we moved we didn't know
you know and like you know we're
self-employed so we have
self-employment insurance and the
website is crappy
and it was we're like we're like okay
for our insurance hospitals that are
that are under our insurance under our
insurance is like search thing and it
said that there were none
in 20 miles and we're like that can't be
right you know so we
we picked you know a big one just hoping
that like the big ones will take our
insurance but it does suck that like
that's like a worry you have to have you
know there's this uh
there's this subreddit called a boring
dystopia
a boring dystopia is that googling what
hospitals nearby
accept your insurance while your
appendix is rupturing
yeah how much is this going to cost
i know also at the time we didn't know
how
exactly how urgent things were oh yeah
and we didn't spend too much time we
spent maybe like
10 minutes no 15. no more
we just spent at least 30 minutes
remember we called
yeah we got off of the calls i forgot
about that
and then like all of that we called so
many places so many different times
and then they were transferring and then
we were on i forgot about that
yeah boring dystopian
yes then caitlyn drove me in and um
you know we checked in and the hospital
everyone there was really professional
and good yeah
um you know we were definitely i
definitely got put into the like um
like waiting room the non-urgent cue
basically yeah the non-urgent cue and
i'm not sure
so so i did get um my ct scan which did
show appendicitis
so they knew i had appendicitis like
what although interesting i got in like
we got in at six and they knew i had
appendicitis by like
11. probably even earlier probably even
earlier um i think it was like
nine or so um and interestingly when you
describe your symptoms to them they
thought it was like gallstones or kidney
stones
yeah and then they did the skin and
they're like it's appendicitis but you
don't have any perforations
so um you know we'll get you in for
surgery but it could be a bit
yeah he did have perforations we just
they couldn't see it on the scans
or maybe it happened while i was there
no they said it they said it would have
happened earlier okay because otherwise
you wouldn't have had the abscess
oh okay okay and they said that that
takes like a week
to form so it had been perforated for
like a week like it was leaking for like
a week
ew
um but yeah so but when they looked at
the scans
they were just like it's acute
appendicitis there doesn't seem to
be any perforations um you know
this is the surgeon who's gonna remove
it and
it'll probably be towards the end of the
day just because
he like they saw it as a non-urgent
thing
so we were the last surgery of the day
yeah and the surgeon already it was all
like booked until the end of the day
so i you know there wasn't many choices
that were given
you know it's like well this is what you
got going
i even i even thought like you know
because i was like ooh surgery that
seems like a lot i
we even thought and we looked into and
researched just doing like
antibiotics and everything because if
you have very minor appendicitis
you can kind of treat it with apparently
according
to some you know yadda yadda
don't listen to us we're not medical
professionals
right but like but i know that's like
what that's what william william had
done yeah
and um we knew that was the thing that
sometimes but his hadn't burst
no and leaked yeah yours didn't
like fully fully it didn't it didn't
spread
into my entire gut yeah but it was like
on the verge
yeah it was still somewhat contained
yeah um
but yeah i it was like such a weird
experience because we spent
from yeah about six a.m until your
your surgery was at like 5 p.m
so we spent about 12 hours in various
waiting rooms
honestly pretty out of it honestly
passed by pretty quickly for me what was
going through your head
um panic mixed with like
i don't know just like a panic mixed
with not being able to do anything
also so like trying to just be zen about
things
because like you can't i mean if for a
little bit we were doing research on
like the antibiotics or
surgery and then you know we were
talking to the doctors and they were
like definitely surgery so we're like
okay
and like doing research on that and um
kind of preparing but then at a certain
point you're just like i can't really do
anything
although so most of my head was like
making sure that you were
like once we kind of done any initial
research like frantic googling
which i'm sure all the nurses and
doctors love when you're like what about
this
well what about this you know um so then
i was just making sure you were okay
because especially that first waiting
room
it was so cold and you got the shivers
bad we had like seven blankets on that
that was
oh yeah that was in one of the earlier
ways that was the earliest waiting room
and at first you were okay but then like
as you laid there more i don't know if
your fever was
super intense shakes yeah you got you
they checked your temperature and your
fever wasn't anything crazy but
you just got really really really cold
yeah and so
i just kept asking for more and more
blankets like every new nurse that would
i just pop my head out because there's
like a little curtain around you and i'd
be like
can i get a few blankets oh can i
i had like seven blankets on me probably
plus you had seven seven or eight
blankets plus your hoodie
plus my hoodie and i was still shaking
yeah and i was like over there like
like rubbing on your arms like rubbing
on your legs and i even
like try we tried putting the laptop on
your lap because it was warm
it was too heavy it was too heavy yeah
but we're just like
trying everything and i'm my adrenaline
was going because normally i'm like a
chilly person it was cold in there but
my adrenaline was going so much i was
just like
hey nurse he's still really really cold
should we should we check his
temperature again
is everything okay do we need to like
call the doctor can i get more can i get
more blankets come here
oh sorry sorry um
and so that was you know
that's the that being like that phase of
it being in that room was the hardest
because it was just so cold and you were
so uncomfortable
yeah and then there you know they took
us to the pre-op room and that one
wasn't as cold and it was like okay
things are
like operation's gonna be soon if we're
in the pre-op room yeah
i think that i tried to be pretty zen
and i tried to be pretty like thankful
like well at least we caught it now and
at least we're
at the hospital and and also we didn't
know how bad it was
why you know we didn't know how bad it
was also
i didn't know how bad recovery was gonna
be
at that point i thought it was like okay
they're just going to snip this out
it's a little laparoscopic thing and i
can leave the next day
well i kind of thought that it was like
going to be a little like
a little i don't know just well that's
because that's they
said you know surgery yeah when they
didn't know that it was perforated they
were like we'll probably keep you
overnight
just to be safe and at the time i was
like oh man overnight
talk about seven days instead seven days
later yeah
um but yeah um
and also like uh you know the whole time
you couldn't eat anything because you're
pre-op i had like a like a soylent
shake luckily you had thought to grab a
couple on our way out yeah because i
hadn't even thought about that and so
that that i was like
whole first day did you survive on
no um uh my dad brought me
some whataburger at the end
was that while i was in surgery or no
while i was in the pre-op it was when
you were in the pre-op room before
surgery now i've never eaten so
fast because i like you know i i
couldn't bring food up there
um so i had to leave to eat but i also
was like
dying and my dad just happened to be in
town then
or like you know closer in um
and so that's just like the timing that
worked out
and so i was trying to eat it so fast
but i was also super stressed out
because i was trying to be like really
strong
around you and be like calm and stuff
but when my dad picked me up and i was
like trying to eat so fast i was like
i can't eat fast enough i started like
crying because i was like
shoving french fries in my face and it
was such a just
like surreal like weird
thing i'm like sitting in my dad's car
like oh i don't
have to i have to get back up there soon
but also also the fries were delicious
because i was
starving i mean i can't really talk
about being hungry you didn't really get
to eat for days
um do you have a milkshake too that
would have been nice i didn't have a
milkshake i i i had like the minimum
to survive i got food in my stomach when
i ran back upstairs
um but uh
and shortly after is when they brought
you in so it's good i ate that fast
yeah i was i was pure speed speedy lady
caitlyn does not eat fast no i'm i'm a
general
person super slow eater am i super fast
my dad was also teasing me because he he
ate faster than i did
and i was like no no no no no did he
still ate faster
than i'd um
um yeah i got up and then they were like
the nurses that come in to like do the
final preps and stuff
i remember the final preps um i don't
really remember the trip from the pre-op
room into the surgery room
but didn't you say you remembered
getting onto the surgery table i thought
you said you remembered something about
the table being like metal
did i yeah okay i do not remember that i
remember i remember being wheeled
into the surgery area yeah you said you
saw the surgery room
yeah i saw all of the crazy
devices and instruments and stuff like
that at that point
what was going through your head were
you like freaking out or were the meds
kicked in enough that you're just like
i don't know if i had had the meds yet
oh really i know
they they they gave me the meds and then
i went to la la land and i woke up
after i don't remember anything i
remember being rolled in
and then nothing nothing i thought you
remembered like being transferred to the
table
i i think i maybe made it to the table
okay yeah
okay and they're like chilling weird i
know i know it was weird
at that point i'm like all right i'm in
someone else's hands
i just got to trust the system and
then i i woke up and i was seeing you
yeah like the first memory i have after
was like
in the room with you yeah i don't
remember anything before you don't
remember like getting to the room
don't get remember getting to the room
or anything
yeah yeah but i think by that point like
i wasn't being weird
i wasn't being silly you weren't too
silly you did you
asked the nurse if the like hospital bed
was a massage chair
and she was like it didn't move it was
like
air inflating and stuff i thought that
was a reasonable assumption
yeah but yeah
you're like this is a massage chair
right and she was like no
no um you know and you're like but i
heard that there's like lumbar massages
unfortunately i wasn't filming i started
filming right at the end of that
i filmed some of it because my parents
and your parents were both like oh when
he comes out
when he comes out of anesthesia film him
just because he says something silly
you probably would have needed to catch
me like earlier earlier yeah you were
pretty coherent
i was pretty coherent yeah i remember
that part so i was pretty coherent right
then
yeah yeah a funny thing was you were
like um
uh you know there's all the like
hospital
noises and sounds and there was someone
down the hall who was like making a lot
of
in pain noises and i was like i don't
want this like
sound to stress evan out so i was like
hey do you want to put on
some like chill beats yeah yeah do you
want to watch something and so he's like
yeah we'll
put on some philip defranco because we
haven't seen the latest episode and then
i have a video
and it's just are you playing some chill
beats
we never chill we never played the chill
beats
so i have a video of like the computer
playing the latest episode and then you
conked out immediately
immediately you just left which is very
cute you slept a lot the first few days
yeah i slept a lot the first few days so
yeah the reason why it turned out to be
more complicated than normal
appendicitis is because
i i it was ruptured now there's various
levels of ruptured basically ruptured
appendices ruptured appendis
yeah it was leaking likely there was a
and it was like pretty like you know
when your appendicitis when your
appendix is normal
you know it's like a normal body part
but as it gets more infected it gets
like
harder and as it gets harder to remove
and
they just had to do more inside of me
than a normal appendix yeah they said
that they were
append appendectomy it was a more
complicated
appendectomy yeah and it was they were
able to keep it
laparoscopic which is the less invasive
but they said that they were
almost this close to having to switch to
open surgery which would have been even
longer recovery
yeah um because your appendix had
hardened so much and you had an abscess
yeah um which told them that it had been
leaking for like a week
yeah so he definitely filmed bob ross
while your appendix was
actively leaking yeah and then i got
infected yeah you got a secondary
infection
yeah and that that which they still
don't really know what it is
you're just taking extra antibiotics now
yeah we have a follow-up soon
yeah um but uh yeah so i'm still
recovering from that i mean and this is
well from both
yeah this is like day 12 or something
like that
after the um since the surgery
wednesday thursday fridays yeah you're
on like the 11 or 12
um post-op and 11 yeah
um yeah
yeah so it was it was more complicated
when they thought
so they were like oh he might need to
stay
four or so days and then it became seven
days luckily we got out on on day seven
yeah but i couldn't i didn't have food
for probably
um like five days five or six days
yeah well you couldn't keep down the
liquid so they kept
they wouldn't upgrade you to food until
you could keep down the liquids and they
kept
when you couldn't keep down the liquids
they would bump you back to iv
only and then you kind of have to start
over the process and then they're like
changing the meds and
all this other stuff yeah yeah you had
several medicine changes
my review of appendicitis i wouldn't
recommend it yeah do not
do not recommend uh you know the
appendectomy was a lot more intense than
i thought because i thought like
okay well you know people get
appendectomies all the time
is kind of what i thought yeah and that
is true it's very
common yeah i mean there are so many
people in the comments but not all
appendectomies are made equal
that's true and it's still surgery yeah
still surgery yeah
um so yeah and the interesting thing is
like you know we've read so many
comments and people's experiences are
all
very so different yeah you know so
different so
we don't really know this is the first
thing well we filmed like a very short
patreon
update where like i kind of did most the
talking
this is kind of the first thing that we
are filming
since then and you know this is much
more chill energy
than like a video like a project video
or stream
i'm and um i'm not sure when we're gonna
be able to start filming those again
because it's like we don't really know
what to expect in terms of like
recovery we'll keep on like pushing the
limits lightly
yeah test the waters pass the water
while still trying to take it easy yeah
um and we did
cancel and postpone some sponsorships
just to kind of like
free up the next period of time and like
if
we're able to film stuff earlier than we
expect great we can get ahead and if
we're not
then i'm glad we should come back later
yeah we'll push
even later if we need to yeah um
just cause like you know we've gotten
lots of
um suggestions of like
oh you know evan can just direct caitlyn
in another
bob ross or like do like a cooking video
but i think one of the things
is like you know our default level of
energy
and especially our level of energy like
during recovery is not the level of
energy we need for
videos and if we're gonna do a video we
want it to be like you know
uh like fun video
well also we have a lot of really cool
ideas that we're excited to film
that we have stuff for that we have like
you know all this stuff ready for so
it's like
you know we want to do those ones we
want to do those
and those are a little bit more
ambitious but all you know of course all
that caitlyn
lift things and you know all of that
stuff but
you know we'll we'll just see we'll play
it by year i think
like one of the biggest things is just
kind of like energy levels and like
talking and stuff you know because yeah
again here you can kind of be a little
bit more soft-spoken
and chill which is good to like keep you
from coughing and just like
keep energy level down because
you know you don't have as much energy
right now and we don't want to like
push to be at our typical energy level
maybe we'll stream some games i've been
wanting to game
have a chill stream yeah i'll just play
the game and you can do that
i'll do all the talking talking i don't
know i don't know if we're ready for
that
just cause that's a that's like a three
out three hours of being like
on yeah we had a short one a short one
okay hopefully we felt comfortable doing
a podcast because we were like if we
need to pause
we can take breaks and then just pick it
up yeah
yeah so i was wondering so so when we
were going through all of that
i know that you said that like you just
tried to like you know
be strong and and you know not worry me
or anything
i thought you did pretty good i thought
though thank you
i i did never like you know suspect that
you were super stressed or anything
i'm guessing the most stressful part was
the part where i wasn't even around when
i was in surgery
that was stressful what do you do well
there's they have like a
specific waiting room and they have
there's like a screen
on the wall with names and
they said that there's like a 15-minute
delay on the names but it says like when
you're in surgery
and then when you're out and then
they'll call you
or they'll call me when they were going
to take you to your room and i could
come up
so it's like you know stare at the chart
the whole time
i found a chair where i could see the
chart except
my eyes aren't good so it was like the
closest chair but i still would have to
like go up and look at it even with my
glasses
um so i was getting up like every five
to ten minutes
to check the chart then i realized it
was color-coded so i could just like see
the color without my glasses that have
to get up
and i was trying to like get a little
work done
because again like we're super you know
we're constantly
behind and i you know one of my thoughts
was like
i know you and i know that you're gonna
stress about
like work stuff and i thought if i could
tell you like
like i'm emailing all sponsors to let
them know
about what's going on to buy us time and
like
i'm taking care of things then that
would like cut off or like
take back some of your stress and you
are correct
so i try to do a little bit of that and
i also when my dad had gotten me
lunch he'd gotten an extra cheeseburger
and he was
he was like do you want to take this for
later and i was like no no no no
like i'm not gonna eat two cheeseburgers
in one day and he was like
maybe just keep it just in case and
so when i was in there had this like
cheeseburger in my purse
this little cheeseburger my purse is
small too so it was mostly cheeseburger
and so i i decided like this would be a
good time to eat the cheeseburger
because i didn't want to
i was in a waiting room where i was
allowed to eat i didn't want to do it
later in case like
like the smell of it grossed you out you
know and or it made you hungry because
you also couldn't eat and i didn't know
if you'd have a
or you sense eat it was i mean
it wasn't a great cheeseburger because
it was like hours old and it had been in
my purse
and my personal smells like cheeseburger
it was squished but but it was also you
know what when you're that hungry and
you're that
dead just being able to like pull a
cheeseburger out of your purse instead
of
figuring out how to find the cafeteria
and how to make your way back and not
wanting to leave
the site of the chart you know
you know purse burger purse burger i was
glad i had an emergency purse burger
um so that's what i did um
like that was that was a stressful part
and the other most stressful part was
just when you were so cold
and like like no amount of blankets was
getting you warm and i was like is he in
shock like is he is this fever spiking
and their thermometers just aren't
reading it right
like what's happening that was a freaky
those are freaky it was freaky and we
still don't really know like why
you got so shivery yeah that was freaky
um but those were
the two most stressful and then like
like
you know we went back and forth about
should i stay in the hospital or should
i drive home to sleep at night
i'm so glad you went and i actually got
sleep i i was
really really tempted like i really
tried to
convince myself and everyone that i
should stay
because i was so paranoid about leaving
you um
but like logically it did make sense for
me to try to get sleep since like we
needed one of us
to be able to function yeah and get a
real shower sleeping real bad i'd drive
home i'd get like six hours of sleep and
then i come back
but it was like six like i was able to
sleep because i was so tired
um and i knew that you would call me
and the nurse nurses had my number but
that was stressful
like those first few nights especially
by the last couple nights i was
when you were doing a little bit better
yeah but those first few nights i was
like
and and i like talk to the nurses and
like be like okay you're going to check
this this frequently
you're going to do this at this time
okay and then you'll call me
if there's anything not normal okay you
have my number i have your number
um the nurses were great they were great
the nurses were awesome
yeah um but those are probably
the most stressful for me do you have
any questions about things that you
might have
well you are there for all of my
time basically i think my main questions
were kind of like
what you already kind of hit on it a
little bit but like what was going
into your head like as you're being
rolled into surgery
and then just you know
eddies
yeah kind of like you know this this
whole thing is out of my hands
and i was just trying to be like
grateful for
the things that that were kind of in our
favor you know
like grateful that that you were there
and grateful that
we were able to you know kind of
rearrange
our schedule some um you know and i knew
that like
worst case scenario you know we
we kind of slightly burned some bridges
with some of our long-term sponsors and
you know that stinks and we disappoint
some people
by not putting out as much content and
that's unfortunate
but you know it's like it's not a bad
it's not the worst nothing is like the
worst
thing you know so yeah i was glad that
like
you know worse the worst case scenario
for work
is totally okay and um
you know i was wondering as i stayed
there longer and longer geez how long is
this
how big is this hospital bill going to
be i still don't know
i still don't know i'm a little nervous
we've gotten
so many calls about our insurance and so
many people have asked us about our
insurance i'm like
we gave it to the first person and the
second person and the third person and
the fourth person
how many people need our insurance how
many different i thought
we just went to one hospital like how
many different groups are going to be
billing us
what the heck i don't know that's
another one
i'm just kind of like eating
these we'll deal with it when we when it
comes in yeah we can't really do
anything
beforehand um yeah
but that was one of the thoughts that i
had but i think in general like i think
that um
you know they're
you know it's i think that the the
the thing that fuels us through most of
what we do
is like our happiness and our happiness
to be together and all of that stuff
but it's hard to be like happy in such a
tough
scenario so it's like the whole time i
was there you know i had happy moments
with you but a thing that's
easier to be that was like easier for me
to be in control of while i was there
was to be like grateful to be
like you know to to be in the position
that i was at with work and
i was grateful that you were there and i
was grateful that my parents
you know would come up if they needed to
and i was grateful that your parents
you know could come over if they needed
to and
you know just trying to be grateful for
like well it could be
worse yeah you know and just be grateful
of all the
the things that were like at least on my
side
and stuff like that yeah because you can
either look at like
all the different things we could have
done differently
or you can be grateful that we did do
what we did when we did
yeah you know and and all that too and
that was something that like helped me
get through that some
yeah yeah i know that you do a great
gratitude
journal one thought that i had when i
was like
at the hospital is like i kept on being
grateful for the same things
i was like i'm grateful for caitlyn i'm
grateful for whatever health i already
have i'm grateful for you know our
our you know work our our fans that
understand that we need to take a break
you know i was just grateful for like a
lot of the same things
when you do your gratitude journal do
you just like
write the same thing every day well so
um i it kind of started as a
gratitude journal um
which was basically like every day i
would write down like
it's not really like i'm grateful for
this i would just write down like one
good thing that happened each day
yeah or sometimes it's like something
you're grateful for but i just kind of
left it a little bit more
open um and
i would try to pick something you know
there's a lot of things you don't want
to just like ride it every single time
you know so i would pick something that
was like my cat yeah
i i would pick something that was more
specific to that day
yeah yeah um like i'm grateful that my
cat slept on my lap
yeah i guess simple needs you know
i'm sorry i i keep on interrupting to be
silly but tell me but uh
but it has kind of evolved to just be
like you know i don't do it every day
anymore i'll do it maybe every few days
and i'll just like
jot down a few interesting or fun things
that have happened
you know um
so it it's evolved it's not really like
a gratitude
journal necessarily and sometimes i just
write it down because i want to like
remember things so like every it
probably would have been more efficient
to
we kept so many notes on like keep note
of things
but also just kind of like stuff that
you know our notes were more about like
what times you're taking your medicines
and tips from the doctors and stuff but
also
like just kind of writing down
the experience i would kind of like
write
you know what was going on each day in
my
journal so you know it evolved from a
gratitude journal to like
just a journal just like a quick journal
um can you read any of it barely
handwriting's terrible but you know
um but yeah so it's
um but when i was doing more of the
gratitude stuff i would try to think of
something like oh we tried this new
restaurant today and it was really tasty
yeah you know um
but stuff like that just like i don't
know silly things yeah
i might try it someday because i thought
that was cool
yeah i think you're cool to me it's more
of just like
nice to go back to a random day and like
read something be like oh yeah i
remember that
because like sometimes you might forget
things yeah you know it's so easy to
like forget stuff
so easy to forget stuff but you know
it's not hard to forget
our things of the week
i mean maybe you're at full health
because your segway game is on point
i thought of it i thought of it during
the last few of your sentences so
i was still listening to you oh thank
you but i was also brainstorming
so my thing of the week is there's this
this um it's it's it's so
lovely in a nerdy way it's called
technology connections the channel on
youtube
it's the channel on youtube and this guy
he just has some some really great
wholesome
it's like interesting educational nerdy
content
it's a lot of good nerdy content you you
watch several of his videos during
recovery
yeah so one
video i'd recommend in general is brown
color is weird that's the video title
that's the video title and
basically it totally makes sense brown
is just dark orange with context and the
reason why we call it brown
is because we have a name for it yeah if
we didn't
name it brown it would just be
dark orange or something i don't know
well the engine
yeah an interesting thing was like why
is there no brown light
because there's like other color light
there's purple light there's orange
oh yeah like rgb yeah yeah like colored
lights colored lights
you can't make a brown light because it
just looks orange
it just looks orange it's an interesting
video it's it's it's very interesting
it's it's great it all makes sense if
you watch it
um so that that's my pick of the week
my thing of the week is something we got
shortly before our hospital stay
and it is a um we've been looking for
a shop vac that we can like use as a
vacuum cleaner like on the ground to to
clean up we have
a shop yeah in the shop because we have
a bigger shop now we're trying harder to
keep it clean
um and there's just like a lot more
service area to clean so we wanted a
shop vac to like
go around and vacuum the ground most of
them are
like a briefcase kind of like a rolling
briefcase with a tube
that you hold yeah um but we found one
it's a
milwaukee jobsite vacuum we'll link to
it
as always and it's like the form factor
of
a more traditional vacuum cleaner and
it's battery powered so you have to plug
it in
but it's awesome it's great it's like a
little heavy because we got
we got the big big boy battery so it's
a little bit heavy at the top but having
like a
normal vacuum form factor and then we're
just like in the garage like i'm
vacuuming yeah and you can just vacuum
up screws or whatever
so it's like it's it's it's the best of
all of the worlds i think in terms of
the
vacuum for the shop yeah you don't have
to be plugged in you don't have to carry
a
like briefcase rolly pack with you yeah
yeah
yeah now the collection containers and
isn't insanely large but it's clear so
you can see it's clear yeah and
you know it works for a shop and
everything but um
i think that that'll be nice because we
want to try to keep things a little bit
cleaner now we haven't done that much
woodworking so
we'll see how well um we keep up with it
but
it's it's going to be a lot easier to
keep clean i think with that
i think so too yeah yeah which i think
brings us to the outro
um caitlin can you um talk for a little
bit while i pull up some reviews
i can totally talk for a little bit yeah
we're pulling up reviews because
um as you guys may know if you've
listened to the end of the podcast
before
we have a pop-up prank on the world
um which is um we want people to
find our podcast who don't already know
about us on youtube so people just
browsing podcasts innocently looking for
their next lesson
they find this really well rated podcast
because you guys are kind enough to give
us
awesome reviews and ratings and they'll
be like oh
who's this this is probably going to be
relevant to me since it's showing up and
then they're like i don't understand
what's going on
who are these people why are they
talking about appendicitis
so we asked for you guys to be part of
the prank by
leaving us at good reviews and uh good
ratings and we like to read
your reviews sometimes such as this one
i haven't pre-read it so
forgive me if i don't get this right but
by uh ferret thing
best podcast for cats and digestive
system
this podcast saved my cat's digestive
system and my love for websites
and this podcast can legally make you a
potato illegal potato
my my rap secret lover recommended this
podcast
listen to it please great review
great review five stars definitely makes
sense
and uh the podcast will indeed legally
make you a potato
yeah so you are now a potato you're a
potato you're a wholesome potato
your certificate should arrive in two to
five
years oh i was just gonna leave it at
two to five
here's the your certificate should
arrive in two to five
i like how you just saluted to all the
audio listeners evan just saluted
all right guys thank you so much for
tuning in to the first podcast
with only one appendix look forward to
seeing you in the next one